more than 24 hours after jacob blake was
shot
these were the scenes in the city where
it happened
in kenosha wisconsin protesters
descended downtown
in defiance of an 8pm curfew
they gathered outside the courthouse
vehicles and buildings were set alight
the crowds were countered by the
national guard
who responded with tear gas and pepper
balls
in the midst of it all came from jacob
blake's uncle
a medical bulletin on the nephew who'd
been shot and survived
justin blake said he'd been left
paralyzed from the waist down
he's recovering he's getting surgical
stuff done to him and we're all praying
for his recovery right now
we're encouraging people to protest
peacefully not to be destructive
we want justice and we want proper
justice this was the incident that led
to jacob blake being shot several times
in the bank
as he approached his car on sunday
evening police officers converged
one grabbing his shirt and then shots
were fired
in the vehicle at the time were mr
blake's sons aged
3 5 and 8. the fallout has spread far
beyond the city of kenosha
these were the scenes across the state
in madison wisconsin
in california protesters marched on the
los angeles police department
headquarters
and there were similar solidarity
protests in minneapolis
the city where george floyd was killed
during a police arrest in may
prompting a backlash nationwide now
given fresh momentum across society
by the events in wisconsin if you're
sitting here telling me that
there was no way to
subdue that gentleman um
or or detain him or to
just before the firing of guns
um then you you sitting here you lie to
not only me
you lying to every african
american every black person in the
community
in kenosha there remains a simmering
tension
as a city contemplates yet another
shooting incident
more shocking played out on video
while authorities deal with the reaction
to sunday's incident
two wisconsin police officers have been
placed on administrative leave
the police union has urged the public to
withhold judgment
until the full facts are known
the fact is that for many mines are
already made up
james matthews sky news washington